and um Travis I just have a question for
you regarding the Ensemble you're
wearing did you know it was going to be
a hundred some odd degrees you're
wearing knits so you took off the
sweater already I have no idea um it I'm
just a natural sweater already so it's
not going to affect me too bad
um I'm not sure if I'm sweating from the
Sun or from Encore Beach Club last night
it's already it's a the temperature's
hot so the heat is already brought all
right so how many beers in the cart
today there's gonna be plethora of beers
we're not going to throw a number count
on it there's also going to be Casa
azul's baby don't forget your tequila
Seltzer all right Travis have fun up
there I think he's going to there's a
lot of money on the line for this one
with you guys yeah it's a lot of money
on there you know at the pregame party
last night a little friendly wager with
my guy Draymond we got money on the
table I'm gonna ride with the football
guys all day I compete against these
guys I know Patrick Mahomes I Know
Travis Kelsey they gonna come out here
and perform today for sure what's a
little money by the way hello you know a
little tin
just
just a 1K of course Draymond who are
your picks today well vom texts me today
like did we bet last night he already
wanted to forget it exactly he's trying
to forget the better that hasn't even
started yet so as you know I'm rolling
with the four-time Champions because two
times it's just not enough you know so
you need to double that up and that's
what we got here we got two four-time
Champions taking this away easy not only
are these guys going to win
but this this match will be over about a
seven hole okay Matt they will be
mathematically eliminated by the seventh
hole all right well friendly
Partners
I told you that's why I picked I'll
change my history man looks slow down
yes Stephanie
hey Draymond we're here
to the bridge
go ahead drop one title baby that's well
played that was nice
that baby hook
Community bad
bro go right great shot great shot great
shot this is even better wow yes sir
well there's the birdie Charles that's
it let's go that was impressive right
there
here we go
coming from The Mulch off of the tee
shot
you said it was good
oh I like this Taking Flight down
[Applause]
way to pick me up dog
this guy's looking for back to back
birdies
we are playing the third hole here in
the match back to Stephen Curry for just
a second because when you listen to him
and all he's doing in his house
Steph and LeBron I mean it's amazing now
we got Giannis now we got Joker we got
some amazing people
[Applause]
thank you
nice set up here
smoked it it ain't going there he's
smoking
right middle right there
we'll pull
yeah
it's definitely turning from the right
my home's still with a chance for birdie
to win the hole
oh and he makes no mistakes
all day they even free agency
he should be nice to me
[Laughter]
leave it off to the side just maybe you
can break some news floors after this
putt goes down there Draymond yeah
you're going to Detroit on the red out
of matter you're going back to the Bay
oh I like it I like it I like it um
good team ball right there baby
Carlton night at the Country Club
oh that's rough I bet I bet it wouldn't
take much to talk you into doing the
Carlton would it
you don't have to talk me into you just
got to play uh what is it uh Tom uh Tom
Jones It's Not Unusual
I learned I learned I learned it
firsthand from Alfonso himself man
Rapunzel Rivera shout out to Alfonso man
he he saw me do it one time he said
don't ever do that ever again like uh
we're not Pros
I'm just telling y'all we're hit it
right over y'all's head nice and still
please thank you
okay
here we go
[Applause]
that was awesome
right there
that's what we're looking for
they've been waiting on that
is you watch your Shadow so you don't
want your Shadow to be in his line so
you just draw a straight line
a little bit early but not a lot late
you don't want to get a technical foul
out
here's shadows and not replacing your
divots and stuff like that I teach this
man some etiquette
if you like
oh
get in there let's go right that's crazy
yeah you already scraped Clays his
Trails he already scraped it what's that
a birdie birds
so it's going to take an eagle to win
oh
[Applause]
and Kelsey
get in the holes
four bounce
[Applause]
that's ridiculous
top Tracer technology brought to you by
Capital One
nice play by Travis Kelsey press
on those guys
[Laughter]
hey Pat what did you just say what
I was told clay to watch out for that
hole wow 3-1 jokes
wow oh
that's a little Chief shot that is a
cheap shot
wow
there we go clay
cancer break right now hey man hey you
hate to see it let's go Corey
Tom Jones
a year ago
Steph
[Applause]
but at least you've had Draymond as a
source of confident oh you should uh I
mean if y'all wanted an inside scoop in
our locker room you're getting it full
fled right now
full flesh
three more years baby come on Draymond
trusted come on clay
Trayvon sounds like he needs to press
the bet that's just it I've pressed
already it ain't worth it
yes clay hey
[Applause]
that's a winner for us
yeah
[Laughter]
that's my guy right there oh my God
thank you very much
Steph are you feeling okay you're a
little stiff from the fender bender back
there call my lawyer right quick
mister I gotta call my lawyer Buffalo it
was a chain reaction me we can do a
little class action lawsuit against him
right quick
or you could
trying to chill have some fun at the
golf course Yvonne can't contain himself
he just can't help himself all right so
oh
can we call like a 30 second timer
for the win
oh he's smoking got his head else
already
and you never know
that was the time
this way
no that is a win TV
[Applause]
Eagle pop though
raising money for the kids you guys did
that again today congratulations to
Travis and Patrick you are the winners
of the capital ones the match and
therefore you get this beautiful box
from Tiffany wow open it up gentlemen
show us what's in I know you have a lot
of hardware on your trophies
exactly the same oh yeah say even better
and then like it's nothing like you know
some gold to just you know I mean seal
the deal baby
hopefully it fits
super great cause
they have fun doing it yeah Charles
picked you guys yeah I know he uh he
said that he saw my swing on the on the
Range over there and you know what smart
move towels I'm just saying baby it's
smooth it's buttery all right Colin was
right all four of you play Steph
congratulations on money well raised for
no kid hungry and it's always great to
see out here good sports tell you well
done
all right Ernie back over to you